oh
all right
i'm driving to my house on home about
two hours earlier here than usual
because i'm gonna help take care of my
son did we did we find out what the
point of the video is today i'm going to
tell you the story about how
i finally became an adult
how do you know when you've become an
adult that's a question i've been asking
muscle for a very long long time in my
life i've seen a lot of things that
that certainly point towards me being an
adult we created a youtube channel that
was successful successful enough to grow
be more than a couple guys working in
their apartment now a whole studio of at
least 10 guys all creating things they
love that's that's pretty adult-like i
finally bought my own home which was
crazy having a kid is supposed to make
you like an adult
but at the same time there's still
plenty of things i do that point the
other direction i love staying up late i
love playing with nerf guns and airsoft
guns and shooting them in the office
irresponsibly i like to drive my car
fast i like shooting illegal fireworks i
love swinging out swords and maces out
in the yard so i'm trying to think okay
well i got these things that make me an
adult and i think these things that kind
of point away from it and so so i'm kind
of going all right well what is it what
is it exactly i'm starting to realize
it's not what you do that makes you an
adult it's
how you do it
so after watching tactical reloads you
probably think that i can basically
juggle guns and reload them with my eyes
shut legs flying everywhere well turns
out that's not true so this is obviously
an impossible physical feat
[Music]
a little bit of the magic trick behind
this video why we broke down the shots
the way we did how we actually did these
shots and how we can you can string
these together in an edit to make it
look like you're doing some incredible
stuff if you're trying to do impossible
moves break it down into doable parts
and for the few points where it gets
really hard to figure out how you're
going to hide something with the cut
when in doubt just get really stylized
which is a great way to get around your
weaknesses
let's walk through it in this video i do
a crazy reload take my gun i launch the
meg flip a new one up in my hand catch
it toss my gun in the air and do a 360.
grab it like this toss the meg bounce
off my knee slam the gun onto the mag
toss the gun behind me back catch it and
then i'm done
so this is obviously an impossible
physical feat maybe if you practice for
years you could do it but i only had one
day here's how he did it tossing the
make easy enough you just push the meg
release like flinging the gun forward
bless you thank you
that's an easy way to break a meg so we
actually had two dudes in the blanket
standing right there and i'm flinging
the mag into the blanket trying not to
hit them next up insert what is an
insert shot adrian an insert shot
usually where you can concentrate on an
action that you might have otherwise not
seen if you want to like clearly show
something you'll grab an insert for this
specific moment which is a close-up of
nico removing a mag from his belt strap
which cuts into another shot
with flipping
the important thing with a
moment like this there's a lot of things
happening really fast so in a way you're
repeating moments individually or
focusing on moments individually that
really help enhance the action and it
makes it move slower than it would in
real life also you'll notice that this
shot cuts before i catch it
it's hard to catch we cut to another
insert and this specific shot we were
using black thread it's just it's
attached to the top a little piece of
black tape so it's lowering into my hand
and i'm doing a very over the top
curling my fingers around it so i toss
the gun up in the air once again notice
the cut before it comes back down or
anything else happens in real life i
literally just throw the gun in the air
and start spinning and i just let it let
it drop hopefully not on my head in this
shot
this shot works really well it's a black
string held top we're just spitting the
gun and i'm literally just spinning
underneath it as fast as i can and
that's all that's happening it's the
entire shot it's important to know your
actions like how you're getting into the
shot and how you're getting out of the
shot so that you can be
overlapping those actions to give you
some editing room so you'll notice i
start to reach for it there which makes
it feel really natural when i catch it
and makes it feel like less of a cheat
you always want to feel like you're
continuing the motion into the next shot
you actually cut before i catch it too
so i catch the gun a little wonky and
it's really clean i believe that shot i
just started like this and went
fake grab it two things when you're
editing motion like this keep in mind
the eye will be drawn to the thing
that's moving the most in the shot so
from one shot i'm starting to raise my
hand and the next shot i'm continuing to
raise my hand that will guide your eye
other things don't even have to match
exactly as long as that motion is
continuing you pay attention to where
you're looking that one shot i'm
reaching up to catch the gun when it's
on the string i'm making eye contact
with it so the next shot i need to be
looking at the same target and you are
using where i'm looking as a cue for
where you should be looking as otherwise
it's a little tiny black object and a
dark background it can be hard to follow
i tossed the makeup and i actually knew
it and
you did you know there was vfx no this
is real i got as close as i could and
the idea is that we take that hard
moment and make it the easiest it can be
which is to just go in slow motion
and just do that should i recreate it
yeah there we did that hold on it was
like this
ready and
we did we literally
basically held the gun there and adrian
wasn't like this
so this flip here if you want to watch
how it looked before we cut it here's
the raw just tosses it and we didn't
really necessarily needed him to catch
it we had a pad
pretty close i might have to actually
that was pretty i mean dude that was
really close yeah and if you look you
can see how close we are to the ground
he was actually annealing because we
didn't want to ruin my boot
yeah i'm kneeling on the ground how did
you get that shot though
we could afford a couple tries so it's a
small move like that and the reason
we're low is so that when i missed it it
didn't break and that's not how the
whole thing went down yeah so if you're
trying to do impossible moves break it
down into doable parts and the hard
things like catching something i guess
or like being like a really precise
landing of something save those for
inserts or cutaways and just make sure
your motion is moving into it and out of
it correctly and for the few points
where it gets really hard to figure out
how you're going to hide something with
the cut like the magazine going into the
gun when in doubt just get really
stylized which is a great way to get
around your weaknesses
oh
and always treat guns like they're
literally
all right i feel like we're we're
approaching some decisions we have to
make here my time is starting to get
very very divided we're talking about
movies we're talking about the beast how
do we accomplish this the script for the
beast done we're going to start making
it but at the same time things on
youtube are picking up faster than ever
if clint we have adrian in the office
they're so talented in one place being a
goal i had eight years ago to make an
independent future film and the other
goal which is well we built this
successful youtube studio that's just
churning out awesome videos
and i want to be a part of both eight
years ago we started making youtube
videos and it went pretty well but after
doing it for eight years we know making
videos like we know the backs of our
hands at this point was just last week
filmed a video that we planned and
scripted the night before we had some
figuring out to do on set but i was
pretty comfortable going into it because
i knew been through before we've done
this process and things will go well but
how do i say this as an artist you face
struggles you're in a creative space and
when you are kind of defined by how
creative you can get uh the more you do
one thing over and over and over again
well it starts to kind of impede a
little bit on that creativity i want to
make this very clear very very clear
because this might come off the wrong
way i want to make this very clear
youtube is our life because ultimately
you are special and what we have going
on here this thing this is this is
incredible and anyone who would abandon
this or give this up is a complete [ __ ]
what i'm talking about i'm talking about
adding more fruit to the table the table
that
you share with us the world is a big and
scary place it's okay to be unsure it's
okay to not know what you're doing five
ten fifty years from now that can change
and evolve and morph into something even
better than what you expected of course
everybody wants to be happy and
everybody wants to
be successful what defined all of my
decisions like being 22 and moving to la
it's not about defining or like going
after what makes you happy it's defining
your deal breakers now i'm at like my
peak
happiness realizing that you take every
day at a time every thing at a time you
know everything is temporary you would
never know what makes you happy if you
don't figure out what doesn't work for
you exactly how i felt when we got
married was i had a really humbling
moment like we woke up the next morning
i had like a fantastic night you were
there
the wedding that was she talking about
the wedding
he was at the wedding yeah
is a humbling feeling to realize that
somebody just committed to spend their
life with you my expectations for
what our baby would be like i mean i
thought he would be more of a baby and i
thought that i would be like running the
show he arrives and it turns out that
like he's your boss and you're just
doing the best you can fun fact about
babies um we all used to be babies a lot
of you guys probably don't care much
about babies
and i agree you don't get babies in the
family life stuff until it really
happens to you so
whatever but all you parents out there
and people with babies you get it it's
awesome babies are sweet his
accountability and responsibility right
now is at an all-time low all he's got
to do is stay alive i mean i think the
only thing he's capable of doing by him
oh a little smile
yeah
that's right this is something i'm proud
of dude
hell black he's pretty hands the one
thing he does really really well by
himself
is he poops his pants by himself
all by himself he just poops and pees
and then it never ends i'm talking about
you i'm proud of ya
anyways when i moved to los angeles in
2009 to kind of start my big career my
expectations were kind of like all right
gotta figure this whole thing out we're
gonna make movies i gotta get a
girlfriend it's it's the whole thing i'm
sitting there just a dude a young dude
early twenties in la i you know honestly
i had really no idea how my personal
life was going to go alongside this
whole like movie-making career because i
was just playing that by year but i met
sarah things hit it off it was great
suddenly we're like boyfriend and
girlfriend and now suddenly we're
getting married and like i'm just like
this is not how i was expecting this to
go getting married and stuff like it's
been incredible and i wouldn't trade it
for the world now suddenly baby gideon
is in our lives and he's the best and
he's so cool and i have the highest
hopes and dreams for him but before we
had baby gideon whatever you want to do
something you go out and do it there's
nothing stopping you the only people we
had to worry about were ourselves there
wasn't this feeling of like true
accountability because suddenly you know
when you have a child didn't really
realize we would have to to change our
life and start making our decisions with
our our new family in mind how do we
make decisions that really benefit
everyone here it's like this morning i
wake up and i'm like okay well here's
the things i gotta do i have some free
time here between all my chores and
taking care of the baby it's like do i
play a video game for 20 minutes like
how is that going to affect everything
well if i do this will i not be able to
clean the dishes and if i don't do the
dishes i have to go to work and then
sarah's gonna have to do them in the
middle of the day while juggling the
baby like oh my see it's like suddenly
it's like this whole like ripple wait a
minute baby gideon did we did we find
out what the point of the video is
did we realize what it means to be an
adult
[Music]
being adult is all about being
accountable for every decision you make
because you know that it's going to
affect everyone around you like
sarah
or baby gideon
or baby nick and carmichael
am i an adult
sometimes yes
wait tell me
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
smoked
all right so much
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you